hi there this is steve kaufman here
again with the third in my
summer sessions uh remember that i ask
my viewers to send me questions
via twitter with the hashtags ask steve
and i try to answer a couple of those
questions every week
this week first of all i'm just back
from romania had a fabulous trip there
it was very brief i was able to speak
romanian i was very well received
because i spoke romanian
and i will be doing an interview in
romanian with subtitles next week with
one of my romanian tutors and we will
talk about my visit to romania but today
i'm going to combine three questions
that i received in sort of one answer
and the questions that i received were
one how do i go about choosing these
pattern sentences that i used for
learning romanian second question was
how do i learn grammar and the third
question was what do i use besides link
so i want to combine these to some
extent
so uh with regard to grammar to me
grammar is
largely a matter of patterns
so that i find it
easier
to see lots of examples of the different
grammatical patterns rather than trying
to piece together
an understanding based on an explanation
of the rules
and the more explanations i read the
more kind of confused i get that's not
entirely true but to a large extent
whereas if i can see examples patterns
things become clearer to me so i brought
some it's a little bit of a reach here
but
for example in learning romanian i was
able to find this grammar book which i
can't even remember what it was called
but
it was just full of examples so that for
every you can't really see it very well
but for every pattern of the language
there were lots and lots of examples and
so i read this over and over again i go
back to it as a resource another
question that was asked was how much
time do i spend on the details of the
language versus just listening and
reading this was with specific reference
to learning the chinese characters but i
think it applies to everything you have
the
bits and pieces the grammar rules the
uh reviewing of word lists uh learning
of characters versus the sort of general
uh
you know input reading and listening and
i think as a general rule it's about 70
to 80 percent input 20 to 30 percent
bits and pieces
um details and eventually more and more
output but getting back to this idea of
grammar
to me grammar requires you to have a lot
of exposure to
patterns
uh you can find these patterns in your
listening and reading as you develop
your ability to notice
but it's often useful to see a sort of
dedicated list of these patterns there
was a russian book that i found 53
models
of russian usage
as i say this one romanian grammar book
had lots of examples
again and so here you'll notice that as
i make as i'm answering the question
about grammar and where to find patterns
i'm also dealing with this issue of what
do i use besides link
i tend to buy starter books
like everybody else i shouldn't left
these things so far away just a second
here excuse me
ah boy
a bit of a slow start with all the jet
lag and everything coming back from
romania
but hey you're getting us live so you
know i'll buy this uh you know teach
yourself
or
colloquial
but and i'll work my way through them
but
i continue to refer to them because they
have they sort of touch on the grammar
but the big advantage with these books
is that they have
questions and drills in every chapter
which i don't do
but if you look at the answers in the
back of the book you tend to get a
concentrated list of
sample patterns because they'll tend to
want to drill you on one thing at a time
so i like to
you know touch briefly okay in chapter
eight they talked about
whatever it was the subjunctive or
something and then
the grammar explanation i kind of get a
little foggy on but if i go to the back
of the book i'll see 10 answers to the
questions and so then that's drilling
that pattern into me
so if i vary a certain amount of looking
at the rule and explanation even more
looking at the patterns concentrated
dosage of different patterns
if i vary that with
general listening and reading sort of a
30 to 70 ratio then slowly i start to
get used to grammar so that's how i deal
with the grammar and you know there are
other books for example
uh in korean this was an excellent book
uh called the continuing korean by ross
king
out of university of british columbia
and there are lots of sample
sentences so you just gotta you know get
that concentrated dosage of these
patterns the different grammatical
patterns
and then
try to look for them when you're
listening and reading
some of the grammatical explanations and
the terms used in explaining grammar
particularly in korean i just find i i
can't relate to
but
i think i believe the brain will pick up
on patterns
uh if we get enough exposure to the
patterns both in uh concentrated dosage
through these these lists
uh and by looking at some of the
explanations
all of those things looking at patterns
of the language in use i find uh i get
better retention than if i look at
something like this for example i've i
have bought these books in the past but
i find them very difficult i list you
know i keep it by the toilet or
something you know i kind of review it
but it doesn't sink in
and yet i admit i still go back and i
look at the tables of the verbs but if i
can see them in usage
uh
patterns of them in usage
then that that's much better so now this
getting back to this idea of patterns uh
patterns in the language i was asked how
do you come up with the patterns for
example the patterns that i
uh used for romanian remember that i
wrote out about
150 200 sentences divided into 20 or so
different patterns which i had someone
in romania translate and record for me
and so i mean i think there we just have
to use our imagination how do we select
those patterns think of something that
you would like to be able to say in the
language think of the patterns like
if and because and since and when and
therefore and however and
and why and
these are all the kinds of
key words that trigger certain patterns
in every language tenses is another i
mean in every language we have to
explain purpose cause and effect the
future the past
other relationships
uh so that you know if we even
come up with them in
english and then have them um you know
translated and recorded i think that's
tremendously useful it's something that
we're trying to do more of at link with
our new exchange set up there to get
people to to put up
the typical patterns of things that they
would like to say and to have them
translated and recorded i know that
moses mccormick has a list of what he
considers to be sort of the key
uh
patterns or the key questions and
answers in learning a language so i
think coming up with with patterns is
not that difficult to do
not all
patterns like you'll have patterns in
japanese that
don't necessarily match the patterns and
say english
so that to some extent you have to find
patterns that are specific to a language
because all languages have their own
very specific unique unique ways of
saying certain things
and what might be one pattern in
language a might be two or three
patterns in language b uh you know we
don't have for example uh the same
concept of uh
you know active and past or at least
perfective and imperfective aspects of
verbs that the russians have so you have
to focus on some of those patterns
and so on so
to summarize here because i've rambled a
bit
the question was how should you study
grammar how do i select patterns for
these pattern sentences that i use and
what material do i use outside link so
to summarize i believe that to learn
grammar you need to spend
perhaps you know fifteen twenty percent
of your time
dealing with these sort of nuts and
bolts of the language uh specifically
grammar but that time should be split
between looking at the explanation but
all but maybe and not maybe but
certainly more than that getting
concentrated doses of these patterns how
do you find the patterns well if you
have a book like a teach yourself or one
of those and most books where they have
drills and questions if you go to the
answer section you'll find a
concentrated dosage of patterns
so that's one way of getting patterns
the other way is to just come up with
you know uh 20 or 30
types of things that you feel that you
would like to say in the language and
ask someone to translate and record it
for you something that you can do
there's a number of websites where you
can do that including of course
link and in terms of material outside
link that i use
i tend to get myself a starter book when
i'm getting started i find that useful
and as soon as i can i start to read in
the language so very early i was reading
about central european
um
history in czech
uh
i'm on the internet scouring for
uh you know
radio programs with transcripts so that
i want to avail myself of
authentic content which is in a sense
outside link but i bring it into link in
order to be able to read it so i do use
a lot of material outside link
a to get me started and b as
you know meaningful content that i can
import into link
so a bit of a ramble and i hope that i
touched on those three uh subjects uh in
response to questions that i received
next week i'm going to talk about
fluency what fluency means and how one
can achieve fluency
uh how how quickly can one achieve
fluency and also comparing uh working
towards fluency in the country where the
language is spoken and away from where
the language is spoken so we'll see you
next week and thank you for listening